tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj elogi stiamo suello
bella che il titolo è fantastico ragazzi
io videogame che è stato fatto dallo
stesso autore di matt father quindi sarà
una figata pazzesca tra l'altro ragazzi
dovevo ancora fare i finali di però
ragazzi e per fari finale di borri
giocarmelo tutto per tutti quanti finali
quindi hanno doveri giocare tipo 20
volte questo periodo ragazzi non ci
riesco lo farò in estate ma di sicuro e
volevo provare a farne un altro del
genere che si trovi dallo stesso
creatore di mad bader sarà epico questo
di sicuro perché ha fatto un padre in
una maniera incredibile quindi a mero
anche questo sono sicuro e quindi
ragazzi direi che possiamo cominciare
anche se non ho capito perché nel menù
ci siano due scritte qui non c'è un
tasto start per inizio non c'è scritto
ai no se io cosa devo premere per
iniziare c'è un tasto start per corno e
lui andare a casa da primo ceo si è
chiuso benissimo abbiamo abbiamo
iniziato di merda nella maniera più
assurda ma non importa ai no ecco ok
almeno siamo partiti maledizione perché
certo rosso assurdo minchia manco ci
fossero e la lampada che passa un minore
il telefono la mia madre che mi chiede
sto mangiando come al solito
datemi il secondo ragazzi però devo
rispondere all'azione pronto occhi è che
mi disturba mentre sto giocando
meravigliosa ah beh bella bella risposta
bellissima
qui la linea che succeda di nuovo
e la chi è nessuna risposta rimuoverla
stupido
ma mi sembra nello per il culo
rispondendo alla mezza a carico si è una
marca di di t shirt giapponese le
risposte sono un optional al telefono
ragazzi non hanno senso e che è successo
nel divertimento più un cazzo bene era
quando uno è la peloro è il passo di
musica ai no ma deve andare così io mi
sto sbagliando io non lo so se ogni
volta come prima ma è spuntato mei nel
menu allora hai rotto le palle
non so se ti è chiara sta cosa pronto e
acari vero chi cazzo è acari non lo so
rispondi per favore
che cosa vuoi che risponda infatti le
risposte ce l'hai del chi cazzo era
quella brega sono una pizza and 7 non
replay
nessuna risposta è ei dove sei ragazzi
si aggiungono cos'è il menù che non ho
capito perché ti ho vista lurida stronza
cosa era quello che ha notizia qui e
dede ed è uscito un pupazzo a caso
sembra che sia vivo dio mio ragazzi cè
un tavolino che si è mosso russo se no è
caduto il ketchup erano una bottigliata
una bottiglia di buon vino fantastico
c'è il tavolino che sta continuando la
devi smettere rimuove arti protostorico
in fiori decorativi sì ma si muovono non
è normale set ed è tutto visto a fabi
sto stronzo tovi state qualcuno ha
voglia di chiamare un esorcista per il
tavolino ragazzi mi fa un favore perché
qua siamo messi nella mera posso andare
a dormire
sono andato a dormire c'è un tavolino
che si muove e io vado a dormire
sembra ovvio e credo adesso mi sono
alzato di matto vista di nuovi lutti e
che scompare ogni volta c'è una lettera
non c'e la prima questo io non ti odio
ma guarda non ti odio neanch'io se non
fai spostare il tavolino di 4 secondi
almeno eccolo come non detto marco la
voglia di chiamare ghostbusters nonché
scadente cosa chicca ma sto bevendo il
vino come se non bastasse già che i
tavolini si muovono ubriachiamoci come
se niente fosse tanto la giornata già
una merda quindi non perdiamo nulla
sì ma vedi di star calma perché tali o
un ceffone che non ha idea sia acceso si
è acceso il camino
ok a parte un pacchetto di souvenir ed
alla mia ragazza perché è caduto il suo
ragazzi non capisco cosa devo fare
non lasciare la stanza scoperto fermo
che non l'hanno stanno stava lasciando
la salsa varranno semplicemente se la
porta era sporca stai tranquillo e se
sei molto molto carino come orsacchiotto
ciò non finisco più un caffè ma se
volevi che visse ed essi mi dicevi ti
siedi per favore mi sedevo non che mi
prende di forza mi mette sulla sedia
comunque non solo nell'umore di leggere
ma guardando l'avevo intuito questo è
una crociata
buongiorno ma che bello che sei ma non
importa ragazzi me ne vado all'altra
finestra buongiorno e questo è un culo
di tutto rispetto
io ero di nuovo su uka uka sono uscito
di nuovo
sono scappato trovata and 2
non posso stare in questa stanza è mai
giusto è di nuovo da capo [ __ ]
cos'è si è accesa ragazzi calmi troppe
cose fregati si è accesa la tv mi sta
impazzendo un telefonino [ __ ] chi
è abbastanza ok per favore e non
rispondono fantastico ragazzi fantastico
nelle conversazioni più profonde nella
mia vita e nuove una forza non vista
weight aspetta cosa aspetto cosa devo
aspettare che a mezzano perché poi si è
portato con sacche 8h [ __ ] che cazzo
successo qualcosa numero chiesta cosa
non me l'aspettavo per niente
bastano
intanto apparire qualcuno è diventato il
tavolino
se non barili in questo stato non c'era
prima perché sai
leggo mi seggo nei vari a caso hai rotto
il cazzo hai rotto il cazzo mi metti
metti metti silenzioso maledizione acari
che cosa vuoi da me ma chi era carina
casa si è aperto il libro benissimo
metti silenzioso per l'amor di dio o
buttano dalla finestra fa qualcosa e da
agosto 9 giorni saranno sei anni dal di
versario con kazuki deciso di cucinare
il suo piatto preferito sono sicuro che
lo amerà altro caso chi ha detto che è
importante il viaggio di lavoro di
domani
e io sono stato tutto il giorno a fare
shopping non potrò dargli il mio regalo
bene oggi sono sei anni che sono
fidanzato ho sposato perché non si
capisce quale delle due con kazuki tocca
il mio il lavoro duro sono stato troppo
cattivo al telefono l'altro giorno
scusami scusami chi
ecco infatti ci sono punti i classici
puntini agosto 25 mica sono saltate tre
settimane kazuki ha detto che tornerà
domani sembra che sia passato così tanto
tempo andrò ad incontrarlo all'aeroporto
è il libro finisce qui ragazzi che cazzo
scusami acari scusami
cosa è successo ragazzi credo che il
dolce diario and 10 che cosa è successo
non è una storia che si sta perché la
stanza adesso è diventata blu porca
[ __ ] e lotto e classic cristo che
leggono di merda nel cascatori cestino
benissimo di te
non so perché ca [ __ ] ne arriva
un'altra volta all'inizio il telefono
perché si è acceso il camino mike adesso
sono una ragazza prima era un uomo
perché c è garantito da sola tv
è rotto le palle chi è chiaro comunque
migliore al telefono quindi prima della
prima vibrava adesso suona pure dà più
fastidio
cosa vuoi da me cari una lettera ragazzi
è spuntata una lettera a caso verror
incontrarsi domani a kharja che è bello
meraviglia dove andiamo a dormire
no diventa buio deve diventare notizia
and 25 entro il 15 a incoming ragazzi
sto diventando tragico con il comico è
riuscito a farmi prendere un po di
caghaz e tramite già che prima mi è
bastata
come sta bussando ma non voglio andare
ad aprire ripensandoci vado ad aprire
buongiorno da eccola lì chiede salve lei
che è una gran [ __ ] senza è diventato
quindi non velica è la madonna che gioca
abbraccia vieni fila fuori gelli acari
vieni qui un avrà un abbraccio sentito
la famiglia perché ci vuole affetto
nelle cose
ma che carini che sono ma che carini che
sono non dovevo lasciarti sola perché se
un gran pezzo di [ __ ] ho fatto tutto
quello che potevo non dovevo lasciarti
davvero sì davvero davvero davvero
davvero è sto bene me lo diceva ci avrei
scommesso a ingrata sono felice di cosa
che adesso è più brutta però era meglio
prima effettiva qualcuno li prima che ho
visto a e prendo siamo insieme e finito
a se ce l'ho fatta
che bello ai no no e no non posso
obbligarlo a silius ce l'ho fatto
ragazzi ho finito ho finito el'ho non ci
posso credere ma abbiamo fatto l'happy
end che sarebbe il finale carino quello
più bello così come ragazzi credo ci sia
anche il bed and kings quindi quello
cattivo di finale parole che in quello
la prossima volta perché sono curioso di
vedere come hanno fatto finale cattivo
perché questo era na figata con qui ve
lo dico io lo faccio nel prossimo
episodio ragazzi
comunque io direi che posso concludere
qui per oggi niente ragazzi se video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione ce ne servono i siti
scriveteli ci rivediamo prossimo video
le ragazze io